We're going to cover
a lot in this lesson.
Touching on both design and
implementation aspects of animation.
Let's start by jumping
straight into some code.
More specifically let's look at how
building animations with the Android SDK
has evolved.
>From its humble beginnings
to the powerful and
flexible APIs we have today.
>From the earliest releases
the Android .view,
.animation APIs let you move,
scale, and fade items onscreen.
This is available to every device
out there, but it's pretty limited.
Here's a really simple example.
Pressing the button slides it up, fades
it out, and then shows a new screen.
And here's the code.
First we create some objects,
like AlphaAnimation and
TranslateAnimation and combine them
together using an AnimationSet.
Then we add a listener, allowing us
to run code when the animation ends.
In this example, when the animation
finishes we'll start another activity.
We're also providing a custom transition
telling the new activity how it
should appear on the screen, and
telling the current activity
how it should disappear.
Once we call startAnimation on the
button it'll begin to slide and fade.
And once those are done our
animation listener will get called.
It's worth noting that you could also
define these animations in XML and
inflate them into real animation
objects using animation utils.
And here's what the actual XML
looks like, back in the early
days this seam XML format was used to
describe animations on views as well
as transitions for activities It was
really simple, but also really limited.
All you could really do was scale,
move, rotate, and fade different
views or different activities.
So around the time of Android 3.0 and
4.0, the animation API started
receiving a slew of major upgrades.
The API for basic view animations
got a lot simpler and easier to use.
Here's that same animation
from before with the new API.
Notice how the API uses
a fluent interface.
You could chain together multiple calls
like .animate, .alpha, .translationY.
This made for a much more compact code,
more importantly,
you could also now animate
any property on any object.
So while before you could animate
the x position of a view,
you could now also animate
a buttons text color for example.
So here's a quick example of this, and
note that the Argbevevlatuator tells the
object animator what text color to set,
ranging between black and red,
over the course of one second.